[Music]
in the netherlands it rains a lot since
i grew up the weather is really changing
it rains more it rains more heavy and
it's getting warmer as well people
have a tendency to complain about the
weather i think it's beautiful when you
hear the rain it really changes space
and it also sustains growth
i wanted to make something to celebrate
the weather
[Music]
made bahrain started after i got the
heritage of my grandfather this heritage
was a collection of calendars where he
wrote down every day the weather
conditions
when i was doing my masters i was
thinking like how can i
actually map the weather
and then i started to doing the same as
my grandfather but then with textiles i
made this technique previa caffi which
is drawing with rain
[Music]
there are two ways to make made by rain
textiles one i call analogue version and
the wonder digital version when i'm in
the hake
at my studio and it starts to rain i go
up on the roof and for the analog
version i use
two layers of textile and of ink with
paper and when the rain hits the surface
the paper gets wet and it starts to
bleed so that makes that the white cloth
becomes black or blue or depending on
the color the digital version
is prepared with a layer of ink already
on the cloth
and when the rain hits the surface the
ink starts to bleed
[Music]
after i put it in the rain i fixate the
textiles and then you can wear it
with this technique you can see every
raindrop and every little detail in the
ring
[Music]
so after i
fixate my textiles i check the data from
the weather station
in order to really finalize the moment
and the the data which is silk screened
upon the textile
with our data comes in statistics
and i wanted to make a more visual way
of archiving weather
on the textiles i note the location the
date the time interval the millimeters
of rain and the weather
circumstances and i do this because i
see the textiles as documents so they're
all unique five minutes of drizzle is
very different than five minutes of
heavy rainfall
i hope that with the textiles that i
make people get a new awareness of rain
and a new relationship with the
environment
i hope people see the beauty as well not
only the pouring rain and
waiting for it to be dry to continue
your daily life
[Music]
you